do you think lawsuits are the answer to
stop some of this stuff I'm also
realizing right now that we are run way
to fix this is becoming perilously short
like we're getting to the abyss pretty
damn quick the 2020 election is right
around the corner and that seems to me
to be what this is all ramping up to
absolutely the Covington case was such a
glaring example of that so I was on
vacation in Mexico yeah okay so let's
just go all in there Covington right now
yeah so it was a little town north of
part of our outdoors is hanging out just
you know go through Twitter and I poor
son of a [ __ ] on vacation let's see
what happens yeah so I see Maggie
Haberman the premiere reporter for the
premiere news publication in the country
covering American pilot New York Times
yeah exactly
basically calling for the expulsion of a
bunch of kids that she's never met that
she doesn't know they sent an event she
didn't see and I found that so shocking
I was like we're crossing a whole new
line now if we're gonna go it's one
thing to go after what somebody said ten
years ago that's problematic on its own
terms we'll get to that in a little bit
- yeah I thought we have statutes of
limitations for but the is that you're
not gonna be held responsible for what
she did when you're ten but the or when
you're 20 when you're 40 but the here
these kids were we're just going up to
DC to be part of the pro-life March and
usually the pro-life March have I've had
family participate in that there they're
just having fun they're not mean they're
not out there harassing people they're
just expressing what they believe these
kids are having fun probably the first
time ever to Washington DC there by the
Lincoln Memorial was beautiful Memorial
and all of a sudden they start getting
harassed out of the blue and they have
likely never met the black Hebrew
Israelites some of us that have know
what's coming ivorie I lived in New York
City for many years I did yell there by
these guys many times every insult don't
it man it's like really what they're
almost like an insult comic
dreams yeah they find something go next
than the next thing the next are like
bad Don Rickles Oh exactly
yeah the worst version yeah right so you
combine Farrakhan with Don room yeah
right so but these kids have no idea
yeah and they have an african-american
friend that's there with them and he's
being attacked and so they start
defending him they
start attacking making various anti-gay
slurs there they they question they
respond back to that in defense of
people who are gay yeah so it's like
these are not mean kids these are kids
trying to handle a shocking environment
they decide to go internal and start
okay let's not deal with these guys
let's do our school tears one of their
school tears is the old hike as the
Haiku dance which is the great New
Zealand rugby team all black yeah I in
fact two weeks before it's shown it to
my son sounds like look at how awesome
there's oh it's awesome it's a hole over
YouTube by the way anyone can watch it
and absolutely it so when I first saw it
in the movie with Matt Damon yeah yeah
yeah that's a greatest sports dance I've
ever seen yeah so the in fact before if
I want to get inspired by something I'll
just put it on go get ready
yeah so the so they do that is part of
it that's why when the kids turn its
clothes off and it's right after that's
happening then all of a sudden a Native
American comes up with some friends and
he's dead doing the drums so two-thirds
of the kids think oh he's joining in
because we just did that good thing oh
this is great and what do they know the
most popular Native American sports
thing they know is this is a Tomahawk
Chop
yeah from from the Florida State from
Kansas City Chiefs Indian grade all the
places where they're familiar in there
it's right on the border of the Kentucky
Ohio border so the kind of programs
they'd be familiar with that's what they
see not nobody's mocking him nobody's
chanting build the wall out of nobodies
blocking him nobody's surrounding him
and then at one point they started some
of the kids had to figure out okay
something's odd because some of the
people behind him are saying go back to
Europe in sling whoa where did that come
from
and then they realized something's weird
then they just leave and then as they're
on their bus home all of a sudden their
lives are being upended and they're not
being upended by just some random body
counts who started they're being upended
by Kathy Griffin who's calling for them
to be doxed they're upended by Maggie
Haberman calling for them to be expelled
they're upended by Matthew Dowd who's on
ABC whose it was a prominent Catholic on
ABC saying bad things need to happen to
these kids and a navarro who's saying
bad things need to happen to these kids
almost the entire media and then you
have Hollywood celebrities calling for
them to be put through the shredder for
them to be attacked for them to be you
had a writer who claimed to be part of
Saturday Night Live say she's gonna
extend sexual favors for anybody who
physically assaulted these people I was
like these are private kids these are by
the way these are blue check verified
people these are not fake account people
on Twitter yes you should pay attention
- that we've verified that we've
validated that we've authenticated that
we've authorized and in Twitter social
media does almost nothing about this
in fact they run with the fake news
story and these kids lives are almost
over in five seconds based on a
misleading video and so I saw it and I
when I first saw their videos like oh
that's gonna be fake news story just
because you know DC politics you know
you know lefty protest culture you know
the chances that a bunch of Catholic
kids came up and found a lefty to harass
isn't that real high in watch DC said it
happened in a small town in Alabama okay
maybe but there's like this story
doesn't make sense yeah and so I was
like okay that will probably blow over
and that was well getting on a plane to
go to bucerias then I get to Busan see
these things and I'm like they're gonna
destroy these kids lives and I realize
if they think if they can do this they
can do anything to anyone at anytime
anywhere and that's exactly so then you
started tweeting about it alongside a
couple other people and I thought a
couple other people in the legal world
yeah and I thought all right I've got to
talk to this guy because if this one
doesn't get corrected which fortunately
thanks to you and it's ongoing you and
some other people it is getting
corrected right I thought if this one
doesn't get corrected if we let them
demolish high school students we're done
exactly we are done so can you catch us
up on sort of where where this is all at
now so what I did initially is I first
is proud of tweeted said if anybody
wants to sue Maggie Haberman now
represent for free and I was just
adjective you know just ticked off and
and I tuned in to Twitter to like two
days later when I came back and all of a
sudden it blown up and I'm getting all
these inquiries and I'm like okay I
realized that this is becoming very
high-profile and so I go on Fox and my
goal is to get everybody to start to
retract start to back up start to retell
the different story and a lot and
fortunately almost all the institutional
media starts to backtrack fast so to be
clear you did not want to go to legal
route actually you were given everybody
I mean I saw you do this you gave them
the chance guys just delete the tweets
did you even ask them to issue apologies
I don't even remember this but all I
said was I said that ever he's got 48
hours to do one of three things yeah
either correct or delete or apologize
just do something to correct the record
mm-hmm and get me to her credit
congresswoman Omar who usually has no
problem saying anything under
nerd she did she did it within an hour
but she only did it because roll call
covered my story right so his roll call
covered my stories like oh maybe I can
get sued and what you know took it -
yeah and by the way right before that
she had sent out a tweet linking them to
white supremacists and a whole bunch of
it she libel them and hold me new unique
ways yeah I leave it to her to figure
out a way to do that yeah the this is a
member of Congress by the way yeah you
have senator Warren who's running for
the presidency of the United States
repeating false statements about these
kids well that's because she's Native
American yeah yes yes exactly yes I
stand up for her truck yeah the like
they portrayed him as a Native American
elder well I clerked for Native American
tribes I worked for one of these
old-school lefty one of the best trial
lawyers in the country and I was like I
was like I don't think he's an elder of
that particular tribe then I realized
they were just confusing the terms
because he's elderly they were gonna
call him an elder I was like that's an
insult to old man most Native American
elders are very carefully selected they
take their job very seriously in fact
their court system if we had an ideal
court system in the world it would be
the Native American elder systems I'd be
all for it because there's 12 12 people
sit around and you come in you tell me
your dispute and they try to find a
remedy that will satisfy everybody and
they try not to be too punitive they try
not to be too too involved they just try
to say okay what's causing this problem
how can we address the cause of it and
and their focus on a reconciliation how
can we bring people together so it
doesn't happen again
and people don't feel bad at the end of
it not great for your profession but all
these have a much better system I'd be
all for it I mean happy happily forfeit
my law degree to see that system put in
place have the 12 members of your
community yet to decide these kind of
disputes and find ways to put people
back together and protect all the things
that matter to us rather than deepening
the division and the bitterness that
exists and the legal system often
creates that people often leave it even
when they win unsatisfied and so the so
but so they put this guy in that context
just like he wasn't a Vietnam War
veteran the was really not really being
accurate they're trying to script a
narrative trying to tell a story but
doing it to these kids and include the
message was if we can destroy them we
can destroy you it was an ultimate
exemplar mechanism of media narrative
structuring and that's why I volunteered
to help them out and so now represent 14
families in Covington Oh about 90% of
the people I went on Fox and said 48
hours notice just
clean it up and we'll be done and even
after that have given people additional
opportunities and additional
opportunities please take it down please
correct that none of the family members
want to sue they don't wanna deal with
the nightmares of the legal system they
don't have to go through all that hassle
or Atal but they want the record
corrected and they don't want to happen
to anyone else that's it and so I was
like let's set a record let's set a
pattern let's at a precedent ear that
this can get corrected and remedied that
you can't do this to these kids you
can't do this to these people that you
do have standards you have to be bound
by those standards you have to be
governed by those standards and you have
to act according to those standards for
those that refuse to do anything about
it they're gonna be sued yeah so some of
them still left the tweets up or didn't
apologize
Griffen Matthew Dowd oddly enough Maggie
Haberman senator Warren congresswoman
Holland those are the five highest
profile examples of people who refuse to
correct when you see a mob descend it's
a little it's a little hard to figure
out how coordinated it is whether it's
groupthink is this coming from the top
is this organic as much as you've had to
deal with these things and especially
since you dealt with the most recent one
that's still unfolding right now what's
your take is it a little bit of
everything it's two different things one
is there start to green-light mob
culture that's what was scary here
because this started out with a bot
account
who who is spreading it through sort of
liberal ideological culture who is
trying to create an online mob but the
reality is that online mob would have
never reached critical mass at least as
related to these kids without the blue
checkmark crowd saying yeah yeah yeah
mm-hmm and that's the problem there the
green light for online mob behavior and
that's why they have to be stopped and
then they have to correct their actions
or they have to be remedied in court
because they are the ones that are
permitting it and expanding it and for
them I don't know how often it's
deliberate and how often is a cultural
mindset I used to call it cotton ball
culture so in the south people used to
go to the cotton ball they're a part of
the privileged classes when they're 16
and 17 and they're sort of in court
incorporated and acculturated to a
certain mindset so it's nothing they'll
get together and conspire but that they
have a certain point of view that's
that's been created by this culture they
share and I think there's some of them
online mob culture that's been festering
over the pass
half-decade decade and the worst part of
it is that continue to be greenlight by
institutional people or people with big
platforms and big power are you shocked
also how the racial element has become
so blatant so it was like these kids are
white so you know they have punchable
faces or or excusing the black
Israelites because they're black so they
can call these kids [ __ ] and that's
okay even though you're supposed to
defend gay people but I guess if it's
black people you know they create this
oppression a little intersectional yeah
this intersexual lunacy so are you just
shocked how how solidified that is in so
many people's brains
it's extraordinary for like two
different whenever I see people do it or
raise it my instinctual view is it was
like well what does that person actually
done for civil rights
so like when I've been attacked I'm like
well I've done civil rights for twenty
years I've done very difficult cases in
very difficult places advocating for
civil rights so I was like is this for a
person really out there trying to help
protect people or is it somebody who
wants a social brownie point in social
prestige point for being on the right
political side and that's 95 percent of
these are people that aren't actually
doing anything to improve the well-being
of African Americans and Latinos in this
country the second part of it is it's
become social prestige to out people
that are up that over a particular
disfavored political class and it
happens to be that right now are
disfavored political classes are my
people our men are people of certain
sort of parts of the country certain
political orientation kids wearing mega
hats exactly I was like that's the same
sort of bigotry the bigotry doesn't know
color bigotry is bigotry and this is
just racial bigotry disguised as as
trying to protect people they're not out
to protect people they're out to hurt
and harm people and they just want to
feel morally justified when they do it
so when you now have to have to move
forward on this lawsuit that you're
saying you're going into not really
because you want to you're giving these
people a chance to go out how does this
even work logística Lee when you're
going after people that have nothing to
do with each other other than they all
did it on the same platform so we're
gonna bring it as a class claim so all
the plaintiffs will be combined so all
14 kids will be one group of plaintiffs
and all the defendants will be combined
so the so you can combine the defendants
together when there's a common nucleus
of facts and they're behaving in a
coordinated way even if it doesn't rise
to the level state legal conspiracy or
aiding and abetting which it may in some
of these instances the effect of it is
you can add them together because for
judicial economy purposes they're all
part of the same event and it's easier
for one judge to preside over all the
cases combined than the cases
differently and so it's interesting some
of the left media's client use use of
these kind of defamation claims has done
use this exact procedure and it's time
to use the exact procedure back the
other way you gotta be careful what you
wish for
exactly so let's talk a little bit about
what's going on with tucker carlson
right now Tucker's been on this show I
go on his show every couple weeks I find
him to be a decent guy we have political
disagreements that we have expressed to
each other publicly before but I think
he's on the right side especially when
it comes to the free speech stuff
oh now Media Matters which you mentioned
already there they're going after him
they're finding old audio clips on a
shock-jock Bubba
what's his name Bubba Bubba Gump Bubba
Bubba Bubba does something but yeah
whatever it is but in effect a Howard
Stern like figure exactly where I was
thinking I tweeted something the other
day that I wish Howard Stern was maybe a
little more engaged these days than he
is I don't begrudge him he's living
through a lot and he's happy he's been a
great fighter on our side of the
free-speech thing but it's like if he
was to take the 30 years of stuff that
politicians actors comedians authors
musicians everybody has said the crazy
sexual acts that have been done in that
see all those things and said you know
what this is all part of life right all
say things we get in atmospheres where
you joke differently this way then you
would that way all of these things like
I would love to help have him aiding us
right now in this fight oh great so
that's just one piece of this but
putting that aside Media Matters is now
digging into old things of of Tucker's
and you know up eternally he said [ __ ]
there were a couple other things and
they're trying to make it sound like
he's racist and he's for abusing kids
and all of these things yeah and I
wonder what his legal recourse is now
he's not apologizing that that's one
thing which I think that's pretty
for the if you're gonna stand against
the mob don't apologize yeah but also if
they're cuz their goal is just to
destroy this man their goal is in some
sort of legal justice right their goal
is and their goal isn't to help anyone
exactly right there's doing something
that I can't figure out their goal is to
destroy a man and if you could destroy a
man you can destroy an idea and you can
get all sorts of other people to shut up
so nicely what the hell do we do it's
very much a censorship shaming campaign
designed to marginalize his audience and
marginalize him from having access to
his audience and to be an example to
future people so that they won't hey you
better not come after big tech which is
really what distinguishes Tucker from
anyone else on Fox or anyone else in the
political conservative space he's
probably the lead high-profile person
taking on big tech in this country one
of the leading guys saying I think
you're telling me I should have you on
retainer is that exactly it's a systemic
its institutional it's and its
deliberate and it's obvious so like I
first got it familiar with this aspect
of it in the context of representing
Alex Jones because I was trying to
figure out why do people think he said a
bunch of stuff that he actually didn't
say or did things that he actually
didn't do or think 90% of what he said
was this as opposed to that and it found
out watching Joe Rogan that it was
actually a Media Matters thing that Joe
wrote himself watch he's like oh no I
saw this Media Matters thing is like who
would trust Media Matters it's like they
they're politically motivated their
partisan oriented they take various
forms of like people complain about
secret corporate cash and dark money
Media Matters has tons of secret
corporate cash and why is that is that a
big problem right here that the
nonprofit's now are probably I don't
know all the laws related to nonprofits
but they're probably in almost every
political case stepping beyond their
boundaries they definitely are and then
what's happening is they're becoming
clearly their partisan organizations so
here nobody would think media matters is
nonpartisan I'm pretty sure they didn't
go after joy read on cable news when her
whole line down about the anti-gay blog
post they defended all kinds of people
on the Left have said all far worse
things and at least are politically
ideologically aligned with the left are
supposed to be in the first instance and
this is the left set of standards that's
something you say 20 years ago somehow
means you can never have a public
platform ever again for the rest of your
human existence this is not an American
standard this is not a conservative
standard this is very much a left
standard the
but they don't apply it to their own
people ever at all I mean some of the
things Joe Biden has said over the years
yeah he's a leading Democratic candidate
for the presidency and then that guy
open his mouth and crazy stuff came well
half the things that Trump says now
although he says them sloppily are the
exact same things that Obama said about
immigration and Clinton said about
immigration and Dianne Feinstein of the
rest of them precisely yeah so the it's
extraordinary for the for the sort of
one-sided application but clearly Tucker
is a target because Tucker's willing to
take on big tech and the goal is there
they're testing when can we use
something in the person's past because
it's extraordinary about all of us what
unites all of it whether it's the
covington case or the alex jones case is
that you have people who are unwilling
to debate ideas it's all about if you
disagree with them then they're gonna
target you as an individual they're
gonna make your life difficult as an
individual they're gonna harass you as
an individual stalk you as an individual
they've already been to Tucker his house
by the way precisely when his wife was
there and had no clue what was going on
and they're banging on the door and I
was reason why Fox went off Twitter for
an extended time period because Twitter
would do nothing about it I mean the the
extraordinary discrepancy and disparity
everybody can witness and everybody and
people like Tim Poole is on the left can
say this is problematic this is kind of
obvious what you guys know it and we
recognize how problematic it is because
they're not gonna stop there it's like
Alex Jones they're not gonna stop with
Alex Jones they're gonna use it as an
example to try to go after everyone else
to scare and intimidate it everyone else
you better not be in the independent
press you better not be in the
independent speech you better not be
sharing a dissonant narrative or we're
going to be able to demonetized
e-platform you debate you be or defame
you routinely and regularly and get away
with and that's why we need to equalize
the playing field and but for Tucker's
case what he could do is he could
potentially go after media matters for
misrepresenting and mischaracterizing
the set of events they have a habit of
putting out a video that D
contextualizes what happened they did it
Alex Jones they would take them where
he's talking about this subject put into
a minute where it looks like he's
talking about Sandy Hook he's actually
not he's talking about something else
and they would say these are all the
statements so Mike they've likely done
the same thing to him right there's
limited remedies I also saw one of I
think it was one of the directors of
Media Matters I actually retweeted it
saying if you think this is bad we've
got a lot more or something to that
effect and I thought this they're
they're telling you how evil they are
because they're saying
we are releasing this information in a
calculated way to destroy a man we're
not just we're not just doing it for
publicly like we found all this stuff
and we're just gonna put it all out
there on day one because people should
know about his past it's like we're
gonna keep the monster being fed so that
it can keep feeding on crime and it's
why are they so scared of ideas if they
think Tucker's wrong than ideas debate
his ideas why attack him why especially
why attack in on something he said 20
years ago on a shock jock show there's
also something crazy you could do you
could actually pick up the remote you're
not gonna believe this
there's a button on that thing that
allows you to scroll up or down if you
see in this thing exactly I mean if you
don't like what you're hearing you don't
have to listen to it if you think it's
wrong you should engage it years ago
professor lash great historian passed
away some years ago he said the reason
why we expose our ideas and debate other
people isn't necessarily to persuade
them it's because they're going to
expose ideas that there are weaknesses
in our own argument and we often
research a topic when somebody says we
all that must be wrong we go and find
out about it we become more informed by
engaging in the public debate process
and that's that's good that's healthy
but these are people who fundamentally
don't believe in free thought free
expression and free speech fundamentally
they believe that you should have the
right thought not that you should have
free thought you should have the right
expression not that you should have free
expression they have combined sort of
the inquisitional Catholic Church with
like 1920s communist huh and they've
integrated the two in their approach and
they're using our legal system and using
our political system and their superior
power and the cultural areas of
influence whether it's Hollywood whether
it's big media whether it's big tech to
suppress and oppress those people who
have different or dissonant views than
them including people on parts of the
left
so let me people like Tim Poole is being
called a Nazi right because he appears
on Joe Rogan and ask a few questions of
Twitter yeah I mean this is insanity so
that's actually I was gonna go somewhere
else but let's jump there for a second
so like for example when I had Tim Poole
on last week there were verified people
on Twitter calling Tim a Nazi and me a
fascist or me a Nazi and Timah fascists
I mentioned this before I've had I grew
up around Holocaust survivors I lost
family on both my mom and my dad's side
now again I'm the free speech guy so I
don't want to soothe
these people but is there some legal
remedy for this if I was someone
different than I am correct yes there is
because for example I took a couple
years ago that Cassandra Fairbanks case
he gets have a role mm-hmm and one of
the reasons I took it is I was and
reformer Lefty by the way she's now all
Trump but former lefty I drinks with her
one night she gave me her full on lefty
lefty lefty lefty yeah exactly part
Porto Rican yeah and she was accused by
Emma roller of flashing a white power
gesture and this was the universal
location this became a white power I was
like what so and so she was on Twitter
she's like I gotta stop this can
somebody help me
I said I'll help for free cuz I like the
area of the case and thought needed to
stop this because they're used to being
able to say I'll call someone a Nazi
I'll call someone a racist and that's
not actionable at law and I wanted to
change that I wanted to say when you
make very specific statements about
someone's belief structure that someone
can interpret and a jury can objectively
verify as either true or false that I
think that should be something you can
sue over so I brought the case in DC and
we couldn't meet the actual malice
standard but the court said yes saying
someone is a racist in a particular way
like saying it's a white power gesture
you can be sued for in the United States
for libel in lies and under the
defamation laws of DC which are more
restrictive than a lot of other laws so
that's established the standard that all
these people think I can just say
anything and never get sued that's we're
gonna make the point in the Covington
case no you can't yeah if you say things
that you know not to be true that a jury
can look at and say I can objectively
verify this we the juries make
determinations about whether someone is
involved in a hate crime everyday they
made determinations whether someone has
racially discriminatory animus or
motivation every day so if they're good
if someone's accusing you of being a
racist that should be actionable in law
because a jury can make that
determination as a matter of objective
fact
and the Fairbanks case establishes
precedent that you can under certain
circumstances get legal remedy for that
case it will never cease to amaze me
that the free-speech crew are the people
that have to do certain things through
law exact such just to maintain free
speech which aside it sounds so
counterintuitive but it's yes so
fascinating so a couple times
you've mentioned Fox yeah I think
there's something interesting happened
here now has CNN or MSNBC ever put you
on no have they ever asked you to come
on CNN hit way back about two years ago
okay so CNN did two years ago MSNBC has
not Fox puts you on right now Fox only
puts me on and they put me on with no
I'd go on live shows they don't tell me
to say anything I don't say whatever the
hell I want I often bring up liberal
cred while like while I'm on there yeah
but it seems also clear to me that
partly what's going on with the Tucker
thing is that they are really going for
Fox there the plan is alright we'll take
out Tucker he's sort of the bravest or
the most outspoken or whatever it is but
really then we'll make this about going
for Fox's licensing and broadcast
abilities and and everything else you're
nodding so I suspect you agree with me
but I I'm amazed because it's like
there's so much lefty media and you
never saw the right trying to destroy
all the lefty media there's basically
one Fox and doesn't mean I love
everything they're doing I don't but you
need some counterbalance don't you
absolutely if you have the approach of
the inquisitional Catholic Church or
institutional communism of a statist
variety then what drives you crazy is
the heresy so you don't look at it and
say geez how many fair balance
expressions do we have on both sides to
the inquisitional Catholic Church
there's only the Catholic Church
perspective and everybody else needs to
be burned at the stake if we're the
statist communists same dynamic there's
one state channel there's no alternative
state channel there's no anti state
channel so when you come in from that
perspective what unites a alex jones the
covington case and fox is these are
three institutions and they represent
different institutions that are giving
an independent narrative so when I was
at Yale we did a history project that
was actually about why african-americans
and poor whites in the South were often
treated or portrayed in very
discriminatory ways and cultural medium
between 1997 and what you find is
historically those communities have
alternative narratives their
grandparents and parents tell stories
different than say the civics book
version they learn in 3rd grade in
public school mm-hmm and so consequently
those groups are often chained and
censored and portrayed in a negative
light so that the broader public
audience wouldn't trust them to listen
to them word or react to them so the
same thing is here like you look at the
Covington kids they represent private
Catholic education what is
Catholic education is one of the last
institutions of independent thought
compared to say all the public state
schools in public institutions so it
drives them crazy that they represent
this institution that they can't control
their thoughts and mind of right because
they don't have access to that it's and
then you even saw in the midst of all
this I'm sure you saw this there was
that guy from the New York Times who
said I want to know your stories
remember I forget what the hashtag he
used was but he wanted to know you're
Catholic it was like ashtag Catholic
school stories precisely because let's
now New York Times let's go after them
once we're done with this thing so let's
go after the whole Catholic Church let's
go after the Catholic schools because we
need people to be afraid to be a part of
those schools to be ashamed if they're
connected to those schools parents
worried that if them skills are listed
on their kids CV their kids futures will
be impaired and not have these schools
being independent sources of thought
outside of the sort of cultural liberal
hegemonic view and the same thing is
strict like Alex Jones represent sort of
an independent part of the press a Fox
News represents in an institutional part
of the press that's independent that
expresses its own perspective that's not
part of the left majority
I mean CNN and MSNBC and ABC and NBC and
CBS evil are using public airwaves or
overwhelmingly on one side yeah same
with PBS same with NPR and there's a lot
of good value and I watch all of them at
different times I've listened to them at
different times but I want the other
side expressed and so what it's this
fear of free expression this fear of
free speech that's leading to these
censorship campaigns it's shame
campaigns these targeting campaigns
these privacy invasion campaigns what
I've told people is if you're ever to
the point where you're attacking a
person or trying to shame a person
trying to censor a person trying to
invade their privacy then what you're
really looking you're doing is you're
looking in the mirror and telling
yourself I've failed on the argument and
I can't persuade on ideas no audience
would actually believe my ideas so it's
an admission of failure and they're
really resorting to these extreme
tactics because they're recognizing
they're losing in the public debate do
you think part of it also is that it's
intentional not now perhaps they're
losing in the public debate I think
that's probably you could debate that
either way on one hand I'm very enthused
about sort of where we're at in this on
the other hand it's very scary too
because you see this socialist whatever
the hell that is rising so but putting
that aside
do you think part of it is that there in
doing it intentionally because they just
want to basically so chaos all over the
place that partly what they need for
whatever their political goals are they
need this system that has been pretty
freaking spectacular for 200 plus years
to appear chaotic so they so they what
do they do they so care it's very what's
amazing is how parallel is the 1920's
street violence in europe so you see
like a lot of the communist tactics that
were used back then and the fascist
tactics that were used back then was in
well we're designed to sow distrust in
the system
so distrust in the institutions that's
it protectively that's it every day now
aoc doing another thing about how evil
we are in Regan's evil in capitalism are
yeah I think with like the combination
you're talking about where there's these
bad ideas that are spreading and yet
winning in the public debate what unites
them is if both sides get presented most
people will take a humanitarian decision
will make a good choice based on their
common experience and their common sense
whereas and so that's why this side that
wants to spread their ideas knows they
can't allow that open fair debate to
happen or those institutions to be
trusted and protected and aspected if
they candy if they can get people to no
longer to not listen to not hear
independent voices to be afraid to be a
part of independent institutions to feel
ashamed if they're connected to it to
say hey if I'm a lawyer I represent this
person I'm gonna be attacked if I if I'm
in the in the public arena and I voice
an independent view I'm gonna be
targeted and harassed and softer than
the rest they want people to be scared
and intimidated to express their ideas
because I think they know that in a non
chaotic open debate structure they don't
win I think that's what they're wrecking
because otherwise you know it's a resort
to these ridiculous tactics and
techniques if your ideas are great and
popular you don't have to use chaotic
techniques you don't have to you don't
have to try to censor people you don't
have to attack people you don't have to
say what a Tucker say 20 years ago on a
on a shock jock show you can say hey I
disagree with what he said yesterday on
Fox and I'm willing to debate him and
Tuckers one of the few people who says
hey you come on the show and we'll
debated that's quite literally what his
statement said if you don't like my
ideas let's talk about exactly alright
so I want to ask you something that I
think will sort of thread the oh you
know what I want to ask you one other
little tech thing and then and then said
I think it'll kind of bring us full
circle here so one of the things is you
know you see me do this all time where I
have to
publicly shame YouTube in Thai they're
monetizing my video or making sure
people aren't being unsubscribe to the
rest of it then rent a certain amount of
people will say but Dave your your
libertarian or whatever you're not
allowed to complain because you don't
want the government about which is so
idiotic because of course I'm using my
voice is a citizen that's what you're
supposed to do okay putting that aside
do you think there is some interesting
legal mechanism if it was to be found
out that they were treating traffic
differently so that's a little bit
different than what we talked about
earlier was talking about content
specifically so you're saying this or
that but what if they're actually
turning the screws just based on not
something you said but they have a
general sort of a broad sense that they
don't want certain ideas getting out
there I think there are contractual
principles equitable principles and
consumer protection principles that are
in play so once you induce someone to
participate in your platform and then
you monetize their participation to me
you have contractual obligations
equitable obligations you can't have
unjust enrichment so you say hey if you
participate we these are the rules and
if as long as you abide by those rules
we'll make sure you share in the profits
for example of monetizing your
individual video and if they don't do
that if they manipulate the algorithm
they misrepresent facts they induce
conduct and then only keep the profit
for themselves or use it for a
politicized purpose that's different
than what they said those are all
consumer protection violations equitable
law violations and legal violations
sometimes recommended by statute
sometimes remedied by common law well
there's no reason for big tech to be
above the law right there there might
also be some legal thing related to
their own board right I mean if they're
doing things that are not relate well if
they're not doing the most profitable
thing their board may I don't know
exactly realize all the shareholders can
take action so there could be derivative
suits by shareholders they could go to
the board but they can also bring
derivative legal claims against the
institution saying they're not promoting
the best profit they're creating undue
legal risk and liability they're not
behaving in a manner consistent with
their professional obligations and their
contractual obligations to the air
they're in own investors and so they can
also bring action and in fact the left
but I told a lot of people is look at
what the left is done between the 70s
and 2000 you'll see a lot of legal
roadmap
for how to go at what they're doing now
so they were some of the you know the on
the apartheid campaigns in South Africa
they targeted different people using
shareholder suits using shareholder
claims using shareholder complaints to
remedy that of people who are profiting
from the apartheid system in South
Africa why can't we do the same thing
now based on the same legal theories
same factual predicate as that as what's
taking place here which is inconsistent
with their obligations and promises to
people I guess partly and this brings me
to the last question it's partly about
bravery you need citizens who are brave
enough you need lawyers who are brave
enough and they've created a system
where everyone is afraid because the
when I go out speaking to college
campuses or even I do QA when I'm doing
stand-up or wherever I go the question I
get more than anything else is I'm
afraid to say what I think and what
should I do and it's usually students
that are saying I want to get a grade
because I want to get out I want to get
to grad school or whatever and I always
think it's like man if everyone's
thinking this if we all just stopped if
we all just stopped acquiescing to it we
could actually change this thing like
that so my question to you is you and
you mentioned your father before but why
why are you willing to do this why are
you willing to put your ass on the line
where does this come from in you so it's
two things one it's it's growing up so
grew up poor in the South got a
scholarship to private schools
scholarship to Yale when I was at Yale
they tried to get rid of poor students
who were there let it protest by leaving
Yale in order to get them to reinstate
their policies and I saw there was like
I'm one kid I'm 19 years old I'm
challenging all of Yale University which
wasn't exactly a small institution and
just by leaving the school and getting
public attention for it I got them to
reverse their policies and protect poor
students same access that I had to
rights to full financial aid rights to
be treated that in a non-discriminatory
manner in the application process so as
I at a young age I learned one person
can change the world when I was a real
little kid I loved Medgar Evers and
Medgar Evers had this great quote where
they asked him why he wasn't afraid to
die and he said most men die a thousand
deaths every day I'm only gonna die once
and I was little kids like I want to be
a beggar Evers like that is so powerful
that is so important that's so
influential and you realize one person
can make a difference and when you
realize one person can make a difference
if they know it here and act on it
year then you realize that that that's
the power that's the passion that's what
leads you to want to change the world
not be afraid of I've had rogue agents
threatened me
IRS people put me under on it every
other year whenever I win a case I've
had a rogue judges threaten me I've had
people say that they're gonna try to put
me under bogus criminal investigation
I've had every smear campaign known to
man I've had bomb threats coming because
of my covington case representation none
of it concerns me because if you
understand that you really have the
powers one person to make a real
difference in the world then other
people will start to recognize that and
they'll act on their power
they'll voice their their abilities
they'll use their capabilities to make a
meaningful difference and that's how the
world changes and that's how the world
becomes a better place that is how you
end an interview can we smoke one of
those cigars you brought here all right
we're done here follow Robert I have a
feeling you'll be back here yeah I have
a feeling that's gonna happen on Twitter
at Barnes underscore law
[Music]